soyez les bienvenu dans ce lol très
spécial si tu ris tu sors mais si tu
cries tu sors aussi qui c'est qui me
touche qui c'est qui me derrière moi des
trucs dans les ne cri pas ne crie
pas je vais y
rester c'est un tééshopping coquin alors
la poupée lodie on la jette elle se
gonfle
instantanément
[Musique]
ça ça feuille vraiment
m'te c'est très
simpleif dans ta bouche celui
qui on est plus dans notre état normal
je me suis AR on l'expérience ça très
dur très très dur tu par je pense que
cette saison est pour
moi je suis pas solide sur mes appuis je
reviens avec l'envie de gagner j'ai un
truc dans les mains je sais pas ce que
c'est non
c'est
là c'est carton
rouge alors on fait le jeu des morts les
plus pourris pant en train de parler moi
ce que je voulais vous dire c'était par
rapport
[Musique]
à